Well, praise God.
What a blessing that is to see that happen, right?
That's such a special thing.
A lot of people put a lot of work into that.
We're grateful for the opportunity to share together
with the next generation, uh, and what worship means.
And so if you're new to our church, we're grateful
that you would take a step to be here today.
Uh, we're thankful and would love to meet you.
So there's a new here area out there in the lobby.
Please come say hello after we're done.
Love to meet you that way. Uh,
also if you call Henderson Hills home, it's great
to see you as always as well.
Couple things before we get into, uh, the word today.
We have a women's night of worship
and community coming this Friday.
And so if that's for you, of course, uh,
please take that step.
They would love to connect with you
and get you, uh, into a, a place
of true community, uh, with other women.
And so that's this Friday night.
You can go on the app or online and sign up for that.
Also, next Sunday members, we have a church family meeting
where we take an intentional time to update you on all kinds
of things happening within the life of our church.
Things, new ministries, new members, uh,
also construction updates, um,
any other things that we'll talk about.
Celebrate what God's done in the last few months
and we'll try to answer a few of the questions
that you've sent in over time.
So make sure those things are on your calendar today, though
we are picking up in our series through the book
of one Samuel called He Shall Reign, where we're studying
how Israel was looking for a king.
They desired a king even though they already had one in God.
They were looking for one on the earth.
And how that longing got them in trouble in
so many different ways.
Where we'll be today in chapter 13,
marks the official beginning of Saul's reign as
that first king of Israel.
But as we've seen of over the last few weeks,
hinted at in the inauguration ceremony, even in the lead up
to it, the anointing process, all that, almost immediately
we learned that Saul failed to live up to the ideal
of kingship, to the reality of
what he should be in this covenant relationship
with God and with his people.
That's where we're gonna be starting off today.
So if you're not there already, turn with me
to First Samuel chapter 13.
We're gonna walk through first the events
of the narrative to begin with.
Uh, we're just gonna take a look first at the events,
witnessing the events that happened here in chapter 13,
and then we're gonna get some
principles coming back through it.
But the events of the narrative,
look first at just verse one of one Samuel 13,
Saul lived for one year
and then became king when he had reigned
for two years over Israel.
And I'm gonna stop there for a second.
'cause that verse is really strongly debated.
There's a lot of questions about it,
how the timeline even works out.
It's, it's a lot of questions.
But, but in essence,
what this verse is doing is just merely setting off the
official beginning of his kingship.
He's kind of been it for a little bit already,
but this, this is really where it starts.
He officially began to reign right here at the beginning
of chapter 13, right?
So Saul began to reign.
That's the first thing we see here happening.
Uh, now there may have been extended period of sanctioning
by God, we don't really know.
But what we know for sure now is when Saul is the king,
this is when he could be fully assessed by
how he does as the king, right?
So before it was a little bit vague. Now we know.
Alright, how does Saul do as the king,
what was one of his first official acts as the king?
Look at verses two and three.
Saul chose 3000 men of Israel.
2000 were with Saul and Mash and the hill country of Bethel
and a thousand were with Jonathan
and gibbon of Benjamin, the rest of the people.
He sent home every man to his tent.
Jonathan defeated the garrison of the Philistines
that was at Giba, and the Philistines heard of it.
Saul blew the trumpet throughout all the land saying,
let the Hebrews hear.
Now we see a new character show up. Who was this?
Jonathan introduced here for the first
time in the narrative.
Well, Jonathan was Saul's son.
He would've been next in line to be the king after Saul.
And immediately we see him set up in contrast to Saul.
'cause what we learned first here is
that Jonathan decided to obey.
Now obey what? Right. Jonathan decided to obey.
What did he obey? Well, this is back in chapter 10.
Samuel told Saul a few things that he needed
to do as the king.
Listen to this first Samuel 10, verses five through eight.
Samuel says to Saul,
after that, you shall come to Gith Elohim,
which is also Giba.
There's, there's a lot of different
translations of that same place.
You shall come there where there is a garrison
of the Philistines there.
As soon as you come to the city, you will meet a group
of prophets coming down from the high place with harp,
tambourine, flute, liar before them prophesying.
Then the spirit of the Lord will rush upon you.
You'll prophesy with them, be turned into another man.
When these signs meet you, do what your hand finds
to do for God is with you.
Meaning attack the Philistines is what that phrase is.
Then go down before me to gilgal
and behold, I'm coming down to you to offer offerings
to sacrifice peace offerings.
Seven days. You shall wait until I come to you
and show you what you shall do.
But let's go back to what we just saw in chapter 13.
Who was the one who initiated the attack on the Philistines?
It was Jonathan. It wasn't Saul, it was Jonathan.
So right away we see this little glimmer
that Saul is not obeying what Samuel the prophet,
God's prophet told him to do.
'cause he hadn't done it, but Jonathan did.
Well look what happens next.
Verses four through seven of chapter 13,
all Israel heard it said
that Saul had defeated the Garris
garrison of the Philistines.
So Saul somehow gets credit for it, but Jonathan did it.
And also that Israel had become a stench to the Philistines.
That people were called out to join Saul at Gilgal
and the Philistines Muster to fight with Israel.
30,000 chariots, 6,000 horsemen
and troops like the sand on the seashore in multitude.
They came up and encamped at mash in the east of Beth Haven.
When the men of Israel saw they were in trouble
for the people were hard pressed.
The people hid themselves in caves and holes and in rocks
and in tombs and in cisterns, some Hebrews crossed the Fords
of the Jordan River to the land of Gad and Gilead
and Saul was still at Gilgal
and all the people followed him trembling.
So naturally when the Philistines attacked
or when the Philistines were
attacked, everybody heard about it.
The Philistines got a little upset that they were known
to have lost this battle.
So the rest of their army, just that little garrison,
a few soldiers were defeated.
The rest of the Philistine army said,
all right, let's go to battle.
And so they began this imminent threat again, Israel,
just like before a number of times in one Samuel,
they're faced with this threat
of a massive army right up their doorstep.
And how did they respond? Yet again?
How did they respond? Israel continued to fear.
You see that Israel continued to fear.
It says they saw themselves in trouble.
It says they saw themselves hard pressed.
Those are words that just mean they're scared.
And so they tried to play hide
and seek in the mountains, right?
They were hiding in caves. They were hiding in holes.
Some of them even ran away across the river.
They were so scared.
Not only that, the ones who stayed with Saul, it says,
were trembling in terror.
Israel was just as afraid as before.
They had what they asked for.
They had a king they could see go
before them into battle.
But nothing had changed. See that?
They were still full of fear.
I and that king that they had asked for.
Remember that tall athletic guy
that sure seemed like he was gonna be
the king that they needed?
Right? Again, almost immediately
Saul decided to disobey.
We already saw a hint of it, but here it's explicit.
He decided to disobey.
Look at verses eight through 12.
You've, you know the context.
They're in this threat right in front of them.
And so verse eight, Saul waited seven days,
the time appointed by Samuel,
but Samuel did not come to Gilgal
and the people were scattering from him.
And so Saul said, bring the burn offering here
to me and the peace offerings.
And he offered. Saul offered the burn offering as soon
as he had finished offering the burn offering.
Behold Samuel came. Saul went out to meet him and greet him.
Samuel said, what have you done?
And Saul said, when I saw
that the people were scattering from me
that you did not come within the days appointed
and that the Philistines had mustard at mash, I said,
now the Philistines will come down against me at Gilgal,
I have not sought the favor of the Lord.
And so I forced myself and offered the burned offering.
So what was going on here? Think back.
Do you remember what Samuel the prophet had told Saul to do
back in chapter 10?
First he said, you need
to attack the Philistine garrison in Giba.
He didn't do that. But also remember he said this,
verse eight of chapter 10, go down before me to Gilgal.
Behold, I'm coming down to you to offer burnt offerings
and sacrifice peace offerings seven days.
You shall wait until I come to you
and show you what you shall do.
Now let's try to be fair to Saul.
It, it seems like maybe Samuel was late.
He didn't come in seven days.
And so Saul wasn't wrong in doing what he did.
Now there's a whole lot wrong with what he did
because he was the king, not the priest or the prophet.
He was the king and he crossed over
the boundary there he shouldn't have.
But clearly Saul was in the wrong as we read through this.
But we gotta resolve the tension
because somehow are, are we not being fair?
Did Saul not have a chance?
Well, let me ask you a math question first.
How many hours are in seven days?
Quick math, right? 168.
168 hours are in one week, seven days.
So most likely what happened here is that Saul waited
probably about 166 hours,
which sure feels like seven days, doesn't it?
And it's like, man, right here
until Samuel's not showing up.
It's not seven days though
because did you remember what verse 10 said?
What happened? As soon as he had finished
offering the burn offering, Samuel showed up.
So Samuel wasn't late.
Saul just got a little bit impatient, didn't wait.
So this is the context. Samuel shows up.
What did Saul do you remember?
He went out almost like nothing was wrong.
Went out to greet Samuel. Hey, welcome, good to see you.
But immediately did you see how defensive he got?
Saul got really defensive as soon
as Samuel started asking a question here.
And almost exactly, this is what's so fun about the Bible.
Almost exactly like Adam
and Eve did back in the garden in Genesis three,
Saul started blaming everybody else.
Hey Samuel, listen, my army was starting to to take off.
They were running away. You were late Samuel
man, look at the Philistine army.
They're right here at our doorstep.
Don't you know like he starts to blame everybody else
that he didn't do anything wrong.
It was all their fault. In fact, did you see how he said it?
I had to do it. I forced myself to do it.
I had no other choice.
But everything Saul did was disobedience.
Here he failed to trust the Lord
by waiting on the Lord, which led him
to fail to obey the Lord,
which then led to tragically God's judgment
in seeking to replace Saul as the king,
God sought to replace Saul.
Look at verse 13.
Down through the first part of verse 15,
Saul had just finished trying to explain himself.
Verse 13, and Samuel said to Saul, you have done foolishly,
you have not kept the command of the Lord your God
with which he commanded you
for then the Lord would've established your
kingdom over Israel forever.
But now your kingdom shall not continue.
The Lord has sought out a man after his own heart
and the Lord has commanded him to be prince
or leader over his people
because you have not kept what the Lord commanded you.
Samuel Rose went up from Gilgal, the rest
of the people went up after Saul to meet the army.
They went up from Gilgal to gibbon
of Benjamin and the and the battle.
We'll continue, we'll see over the next
few weeks this battle.
But but you see it here, right?
In other words, what Samuel says is like, Hey Saul, listen,
because of your disobedience,
because you are not a man seeking
after God's heart,
your family will not carry on the lineage of kingship.
Remember Jonathan, his son seemed like a viable candidate.
In fact, over the next couple weeks we'll see Jonathan show,
great valor and great honor
and he's an incredible man, would've made a great king.
But the judgment was
that the king will not come from Saul's family anymore.
That's how it worked. Kings would pass it on
to their oldest child,
but not Saul's family anymore.
And at this point in the narrative,
we're not sure who that would be yet.
Like we don't know. We don't have any idea.
We just know it's not gonna be Saul's family when he dies.
It's somebody else's family.
We've seen this coming, haven't we?
We've seen this in that,
that Saul was from the wrong tribe to begin with.
We've seen this in that he was acting often more
like a judge than a king.
Even their request for a king was wrong
to begin with, right?
So this whole thing we've seen has been set up
and it should not be surprising to us
that Saul failed at what he did.
It. It's a little bit shocking
that it happened this quickly,
but it should not be surprising.
We pretty much knew this was coming, right?
Which again, we've talked about this already, that yes,
there will be more in the story
and we'll see God provide as he graciously does.
But really the point in the whole thing of one Samuel is
that this all should point us forward to a perfect
and forever king Messiah, Jesus, that we know him
to be right.
This is just a failure on so many fronts
and we, we can rest there.
But for now at this point in the
narrative, this is where we're at.
All we know is that Saul is the king,
but he's not gonna be the king forever
and his family's not gonna continue doing it.
What do we do next? We'll see as we go forward.
But what do we learn from this?
What do we learn from this passage specifically?
Like how can we apply some of these principles
into our lives to help us today?
What do we learn from this section that will point us to
that savior and point us to some change in our own lives?
Well, here's the first principle.
It's that no other king provides what I long for.
And again, notice king is in quotes.
We've done that the whole series
because there is only one true king
and no other king will ever provide What I long for,
we've seen it throughout the book already, this concept
that anytime you and I look for a replacement king
or a replacement savior, it never comes through for us.
It always ends badly.
Isn't it ironic here though,
like rain on your wedding day
or free ride when you've already paid
or traffic jam when you're already late?
Which by the way, none of those are actually examples
of irony, which is even better
because that's what makes this song ironic anyway,
if you're not like 40
and older, you have no idea what
I'm talking about right now.
Okay? That's
all gonna be in your head all day.
Now that song I know, but this is irony here.
This is ironic what happens right here.
The reason, remember this,
the reason Israel wanted a king in the first place was
to protect them so that they would feel safe and secure.
Like all the nations around them had their kings
and they were safe and secure.
We need a king. So we feel safe and secure.
Now, they had a king named Saul.
Yet the moment this massive Philistine army showed
up, how did they respond?
They were terrified. You see that
just like before when they didn't have an earthly king,
they were trembling, they were afraid.
That's irony what they wanted and they had it.
Now they were still the same like they were before.
You see what God is teaching us here?
Like anytime again we look for a replacement king
or a replacement savior, it never satisfies,
it never comes through for us.
God had proven to Israel over
and over again that if they would just trust him,
if they would just let him fight the battles
for them, it'd all work out.
They, he'd shown them multiple times.
Remember the ark floating around through all the Philistine
and they, they did no ability to
have any good come in their life.
They were getting plagues, they were getting death
to their gods.
All this stuff was happening. The
Israelis had nothing to do with it.
God's like, don't you remember Exodus? Don't you?
Don't you remember this stuff?
If you just trust me, you let me fight
the battles, it's all gonna be good.
But instead what they do, they trust themselves.
They trusted the means of the world.
And what happened? Everything started to go off track.
Listen, lemme give you a little glimpse
into the enemy's playbook.
You know in sports you have a playbook
and you guard that very securely.
'cause if, if that falls into the opponent's hands,
then they know all your plays
and you have no ability to beat them.
Lemme give you a little glimpse into the enemy
of our soul's playbook.
He always over promises and under delivers.
Every single time he over promises
and under delivers,
he will dangle something shiny and beautiful in front of me.
But when I actually take the bait, it turns out
to be fools gold.
You know what that is, right? Fools gold.
It sure looks like gold,
but it's actually a min, a mineral called pyrite
and it sure looks like it should be worth a lot.
But you scratch the surface of that stuff off
and it's just a hunk of nasty BlackRock underneath.
That's what the enemy does. That's his mo.
That's what he does. And it happens to us every single day.
That enemy of our souls has so many lures.
He's a really good fisherman because he's watched you and me
and he's watched humanity
for thousands and thousands of years.
He knows what works. He knows what gets to us.
He knows how it looks. He knows what works on me.
He knows what works on you. He's watched us.
And so he lies to you and tosses that out there
and always over promises,
but under delivers,
he lies to you.
That binging that show on Netflix will finally give you
that joy hold that you've been longing to have filled.
It finally will fill that when in reality you end up really
exhausted and bitter about the time
you just wasted doing that.
He lies to you that making more money will set your kids
up for success.
When in reality they just
resent you 'cause you're gone too much.
He lies to you. That ending
that pregnancy will keep your life on track.
When in reality you have to carry that shame very quietly.
He tells you the rest of your life,
He lies to us this time of year.
He lies to us that getting your candidate elected will solve
all the nation's problems.
When in reality you start trading more freedoms
to get it
elected and on and on.
We could go right?
So many things that the enemy over promises
and you take the bait and he under delivers.
It's a bait and switch. He'll pull the rug out from you
as soon as you venture into it.
I've seen it too many times in my own life
where I wander into what I think will fulfill me.
And what it ends up doing is the enemy is seeking to kill
and destroy and he does it.
So I want us to read that phrase out loud again together.
I think, I think just
to solidify it into our brains and our hearts.
That point that that we have for this one,
just let's just read it out loud together.
Something with something about saying it out loud
might help us understand better.
So let's read this together that no other king
provides what I long for.
Let's do it again. No other king provides
what I long for.
Do I believe that? Do we
be, do we believe that?
Like, like we've seen that reality daily, right?
Like I've seen it even this week in my own life.
Like we, we see it. But do we believe that?
Do we believe it enough
to do something about it?
To change even some day-to-day
decisions we make in our lives?
Do we believe that enough
or do we keep going back to that lure
and that bait over and over again?
That's why the next principle here is so critical.
We've witnessed Saul fail at this miserably.
The principle is that
what pleases the Lord is my love and obedience.
When you look at what we've seen
and learned here, it's not, it's not my stature,
it's not my reputation.
It's not just what I say.
It's not even my religious acts and my religious beliefs.
What pleases the Lord is my love and obedience.
And and the interesting thing about one Samuel 13 is
that it goes way deeper than just Saul disobeying
what Saul Samuel told him to do.
'cause look at verse 12 again, one Samuel 13 verse 12.
What did Saul say to Samuel when he was confronted?
Saul said, now the Philistines will come down against me at
Gilgal, I have not sought the favor of the Lord.
So I forced myself and offered the burnt offering.
Now that could be a positive,
but when you take it in the hole,
there's a condemnation here.
Because the way the narrative reads makes it seem like Saul,
what he did there with the offering, what it was, was more
of a superstitious act of
sorcery than a true act of worship.
It was like he was trying to appease some other God,
like all the nations around them.
Were doing all the time.
He's tossing here in food here
and gotta do this right and that right?
And that's what all the other nations did to try
to appease their false gods.
He was doing the same thing with Yahweh,
which means it wasn't true faith, right?
It's what two Timothy three, five describes
as having the appearance of godliness but denying its power.
It, it sure looks like good, right?
Godly things, but it's not at all.
Saul's action had the appearance of faith,
but it was not authentic faith.
He did the act, he did the thing probably even wrongly
'cause he wasn't a priest or a prophet.
He did the act, but he didn't do it for the right reason
or he didn't do it with the right heart.
He didn't do it because he loved God at all.
He did it because he felt like he had to to win a battle.
And how did God respond to that? Saul rejected.
Saul was rejected from the kingship.
The rest of his family would not get to participate.
God rejected Saul's kingship.
'cause remember, Israel was not just supposed
to be a monarchy like everybody else.
Israel was supposed to be a theocratic monarchy
where God is the full and complete king.
And the king on earth was to fully depend on the God o
of the universe, to depend on him, to follow him,
to obey him, to believe him, to pursue him.
That was the king's job on earth.
And Saul did not do it
because without that kind
of heart towards God, the kingship wouldn't work.
If the king did not depend on God,
if the king did not follow God,
if the king was only worried about himself,
even if the king does the right actions,
the Lord would not accept it.
You see how relevant this is for our hearts today.
Like I, I see how quickly this can happen in my own life
where I slip into mere religious activities.
I I do things because I know it's right,
yet not really have a motivation of love for God as I do it.
Listen, God doesn't just want obedience
for the sake of obedience.
Like of course He calls us to obey.
It's good for us to obey his word,
to choose holiness over sin.
Absolutely. That is right.
But he wants our love. He wants our allegiance to him.
He wants us to want to draw near to him, to want to sing
to him, to want to give sacrificially to him, to want
to gather with other believers like this.
Not because we have to do any of those things.
And it's because we get to do those things. Amen. Right?
That's the difference here. Whatcha doing on Sunday?
Oh, I gotta go to church. Whoa.
Where like you see the heart thing, I get to go be
with my brothers and sisters on Sunday morning, right?
That's the difference we're talking about.
And why do we wanna do those things?
Because we love him, because we love him,
because we understand how much he's loved us first.
Like you see this, why do we wanna do those things?
Because we love him. And why do we love him?
Because we understand how much he's loved us first.
That he sent his only son to live,
die resurrect in our place so
that we can be reconciled to him forever.
That's why we love him.
One John four 19 we love because he first loved us.
That's what pleases him.
Like when we increasingly grow in our love for who he is
and for what he's done, that's what pleases him.
Where no matter the circumstances, even if
that Philistine army, even if
that massive army stands up against me,
even if it's coming at me and I'm fearful and I'm worried
and God seems delayed, he's not showing up.
It seems like on my timeline,
we still choose because we love him.
We still choose to love him and obey him.
Like even if that threat comes,
even if God seems late, I trust him.
I love him because here's what God's looking for,
the final principle today.
The Lord seeks a person after his own heart.
That's what Jesus said to the woman with the well, worship
and spirit and in truth, that's what Samuel said
to Saul right here after Saul's failure, right?
Verse 14, the Lord has sought out a man
after his own heart.
The Lord has commanded to be prince over his people.
'cause you've not kept what the Lord commanded.
You saw your heart wasn't in this.
And so I'm looking for a man who has that kind of heart,
who has a heart for me.
And notice who it would be, a man after his own heart.
Someone who understood how the kingship was supposed
to work, that this was not a kingship like everybody else.
This was a kingship under God, not on your own under God.
Someone who knew the king had to remain fully submitted
to the Lord or this thing wasn't gonna work.
Here's the problem. Every king in
Israel failed at that.
Even the king that will come later to learn was labeled
a man after his own heart.
Even he failed.
But again, like I said earlier, all of that is meant
to point us to the source of our hope.
Because eventually there was a king
who not only sought the heart of God
perfectly, he had the heart of God.
Amen. And he was from Israel.
He was from the tribe of Judah. He was from the line.
He was a king
after God's heart who had God's heart,
a capital K King whose name is Jesus,
who not only lived the perfect God seeking life that you
and I can't live, he also died the death we
deserve for failing at that.
And then he defeated sin
and death by coming outta that grave alive.
That's the king that we should be looking for.
And you know what God, God is seeking?
Yes, true worshipers who do worship him in spirit
and in truth, who seek his heart even when they sin.
We see that with David in a few chapters.
But like even when we sin, we still say, God, I love you.
I want better. I don't want that anymore.
I want to turn away from that.
And I want you, he's seeking worshipers
like you and me to do that.
But our hope is not in how well we do at
that 'cause.
That is fickle. That'll change every day.
Had a good day, feel close to God,
had a bad day, feel far from God.
That's not how this works.
Our hope is in Christ alone.
Because even as I imperfectly seek
God's heart and I seek and I fail and I seek
and I fail like Saul and David
and everybody else, I seek and I fail.
And even if I imperfectly do what he's seeking me to do,
I know that I am covered by the perfect blood
of Jesus, by faith.
Amen. And that truth church,
that truth is what makes me want to love him more.
That's what makes me want to obey him more.
That's what makes me want to seek him more.
Because in spite of myself, he sought my heart first.
Yes, that's good news.
We have hope because of him.
So I'll just invite you to bow with me for a second here
because I, I know
there was a lot I, I know there was a lot
that God did in my heart this week
and what he's doing in yours right now.
So just in that spirit of prayer,
maybe he's convicting where you have
taken Satan's bait over and over and over
and you've seen those things as better somehow at that lure,
the fool's gold will sometimes this time satisfy you.
But you know it won't. You know, it won't.
So just confess, confess to the Lord
that right now, whatever it is,
just spend some time resting in the grace
and mercy of God.
And one of the principles in scripture is
that he gives us a new heart.
When you're born again by faith, when he
makes you a new creation,
he's making you into a new creation.
And yet his promise that he gives you a new heart.
So knowing my own, just ask the Lord
to continue to rip out the old heart of stone
and give you that heart of flesh that pursues him,
that wants him, that longs for him.
I know some you've walked
that stone heart life for so long.
So God's got a big hammer.
He can, he can break that as hard
as it might be in your heart right now.
He can break that and wants to,
you have to just turn to him in faith, in simple faith.
Thank God I for
so long have not wanted you, longed for you, desired you.
So God changed my heart.
Lead me out of sin into a holy life.
Change my heart though,
and watch what he does with that.
Just a fully submitted like the king should have
been fully submitted.
God, I'm yours
and I trust you.
Thank you for saving. Thank you for replacing me.
Life, death, and resurrection. And we give you glory.
And God help me. Help us
to live lives that honor you for your glory.
In Jesus' name we pray. Amen.
And so, Lord church, if, if the.